[Musique]
saussez la canadienne ccma canadienne
c'est à cause de l'argent qu'elle a pris
sur la canal insee
[Musique]
est ce que j'avais l'impression que
c'est d'avoir un procès juste lit je
sais pas parce que apparemment le jeu
c'est toujours bien en face du tout le
monde sauf que par genci chose d'
influence
[Musique]
c'est un chirurgien un médecin conseil
est donné
[Musique]
il s'agit plutôt et qu'elle a été abusée
de quelque chose qu'elle n'a pas fait on
arrive
préval
goody ignace à jan brewer le jus
d'italie d'acter un tueur à gages
téléphone via une par internet ou par
mourir
alors la grande question c'est comment
judy aurait-elle pu ordonner l'exécution
par télépathie
télépathique amène t
sein de la commission de nos primes des
fans sont primordiaux
[Musique]
c'est une famille puissant l'origine
énorme tristesse
une grandeur sushi gauche
[Musique]
pendant notre organisation et nous
croyons que darcey il ya une saison ici
à l'aune de sa fille cela est une grave
violation
le
je suis judith brassard je vous parle de
la colombie où je suis en liberté
conditionnelle
c'est une liberté non sans restriction
mais c'est quand même une belle victoire
il manque une autre victoire c'est de
démontrer mon innocence puis il est
acquitté mais aujourd'hui je voulais
vous dire merci merci à toutes les
personnes qui m'ont aidé merci à
radio-canada merci à l' ong et le verrou
et merci pour toutes les personnes qui
ont cru en moi qui continue de croire en
moi
j'espère bientôt pouvoir vous voir pour
profiter de la vie disons et être au
québec et au canada avec ma famille avec
mes amis et commencer un nouveau
chapitre dans ma vie merci beaucoup dieu
vous bénisse
[Musique]